好 今天的主题是SPU框架的整体结构
我是主讲人 谭晋
今天我们将对SPU的背景和框架进行整体的介绍
但不会涉及太多的细节
我们希望通过这次介绍让大家对SPU有一个感性的认知
今天的内容会分为三个部分
首先我们介绍一下为什么有SPU以及它先要解决的问题
其次我们会介绍一些SPU的功能和用法
最后我们会探讨一下SPU的现状
以及展望一下未来的发展
首先为什么我们要做SPU
在进入正题之前
我们首先考虑一个大模型预测的场景
在这个场景中用户给模型一个提示词
模型通过模型的推理
然后返回给用户结果
但是在现实的场景中模型是公司的资产
公司往往不希望模型被公开免费的得到
提示词是用户的隐私里面
包含了大量用户的隐私敏感信息
所以问题是我们可以同时保护模型和提示词吗
用隐私计算技术我们就可以做到这一点
它的过程可以简单的表达在右图锁式
用户将它的提示词加密发送给模型提供方
模型提供方拿到是加密的提示词
得不到用户的任何信息
然后模型在一个加密的环境里进行推理
然后推理的结果实际也是密文
模型提供方还是得不到任何信息
最后将加密的结果返回给用户
用户通过它的私药解密得到一个结果
了解了场景之后我们再来看一下
为什么需要隐私计算
需求实际上是想而易见的
首先数据是敏感的
比如说人年 声音 基因素等生物识别信息
他们都非常的敏感
再比如说收入消费贷款的个人金融信息
他们也很敏感
各国实际上都有法律法规
来保护用户的隐私
比如说欧盟 中国 巴西 美国等等国家
都在最近的十年内出台了各种政策
来保护用户隐私
而且用户数据是重要的
数据可以说是互联网公司最重要的资产
并且在各种智能技术的价值下
产生了越来越大的价值
而且可以预期的是
数据联合在一块
将产生更大的数据价值
比如说两个公司把他们的数据融合在一起
进行模型的训练
那么这个模型将会更加的准确
而隐私计算恰好给促成这种联合
接下来我们来看一下隐私计算的技术路线
其实隐私计算依然是一个在高速发展中的技术
它包括多方安全计算
统材加密
查问隐私
课定硬件等等等等
不过无论是哪种路线
我们都可以做一个简单的数据抽象
这个抽象里面
IS有数据X
BOB有数据Y
他们俩想联合计算一个函数FXY
计算的过程中
IS不想让BOB知道自己的X
BOB也不想让IS知道自己的Y
通过隐私计算
我们就可以在保护X和Y的同时
然后计算出F的结果
也就是Z
如果将这个抽象映射回刚才的大模型预测的问题
那么服务运用方运用模型的权重
用户运用提示词
他们都不想让对方知道自己的真实数据
但是他们俩想一起联合计算模型推理这个函数
并且保证权重或者提示词不透露给对方
通过隐私计算经济数
我们就可以实践这一点
在介绍完隐私计算的需求和重要性之后
我们再来看一下
它当前面临的一些问题和挑战
首先基于密码学的隐私计算
提供了非常有限的计算能力
就个例子
比如所有的数据都需要在定义在数学的预与或者环上
它是一个非常抽象的数学概念
而且往往也只提供加乘与获这种最基础的算字
类比一下就好比提供了一个最基本的电路模块
如果我们想基于一些门电路
然后直接写出复杂的计论期程序
是往往是非常困难的
然后我们想要什么呢
实际上我们就想的是一些高级的编程语言
然后它支持丰富的数据类型
比如说Bulling Int Float
甚至Harray Dancer
然后以及支持简单的函数定义
可以构建自己的函数
并且我们可以把函数组合起来
这样我们就可以得到写出
另一幅杂的一个程序
SPU实际上就是为了填补加密计算
和高级编程语言之间的空白
它利用加密计算作为底座
然后通过编辑器和预刑时的一些技术
然后把高级的语言翻译和优化到
底层的加密计算的协议上
然后并且高效的执行
接下来我们介绍一下SPU的整体架构
其他的工作原理
右边是SPU的整体架构
它从上到下大概分成了三块
分别是前端 编辑和运行时
接下来我们针对这三部分进行一个简单的介绍
首先我们介绍一下前端
其实SPU并没有自己定义前端的编程语言
相反它选择了附用AI的前端
这意味着用户可以用原生的
TransFlowJax或者Pytorch来编写代码
这样做有几个好处
一方面它降级了用户的学习成本
因为它们可以用自己熟悉的编程语言和工具
另外一方面它也能够附用AI前端的一些能力
比如自动求岛
同过这样的设计
我们相信SPU在前端能力上
能够更好的满足用户的需求
不过在目前阶段
我们实际上支持的最好的是Jax
后续我们可能会对TransFlow和Pytorch加入更多的支持
接下来我们介绍要向编一系列录
SPU编一系的目的就是将机器学习前端
产生的中间表达
加上自定义的隐私保护语意
然后翻译到对加密计算友好的一个运行事实上
这里我们选用了IRVM-MIR框架进行IRS的编译和优化
我们将编一系部分放大来看的话
一个比较有意思的特点
就是SPU自定义的带隐私保护语言的IAR
也就是途中的PPHRO和PPIRRO
其中PP是Private Seed Preserving的减息
HRO和PPIRRO是High-Level Ops和Low-Level Ops的减息
通过这种带隐私保护语言的IAR
我们可以让用户几乎写不出不安全的代码
从而增强安全性
这个带隐私保护语言的IAR
简单来说就是任何和密带变量进行的计算
结果都是一个密带变量
这样的话在一个复杂的明密文组成的一个计算图里面
通过这种方式我们形成了一个安全币包
就是任何经过加密变量的结果也都是一个加密的
这样来保护整体保护输入数据的安全
然后SPU也加入了一些加密计算
领域独占的一些优化策略
比如说右上图对于密文乘以明文乘以明文这种pattern
我们通过简单的调整可以变成
明文乘以明文乘以密文
这个调整非常简单
其实就是把明文放到前面来
这样我们可以让更多的计算发生在明文世界中
因为明文比密文计算要坏得多
这样我们就可以整体的提高性能
再比如说右下方
我们实际上是有两个选择器
如果两个选择器依赖于同一个条件辨量
那么可以把这个条件辨量进行一些前置处理
这样相当于将两个选择器的公共部分
公共计算部分提前出来
然后共享一部分的计算
这样来整体的提高性能
相众优化还有很多
如果大家有兴趣的话
可以关注一下我们的代码和明文
接下来我们来介绍一下SPU的运行时
SPU的运行时可以被视为
当做成一个SMD持年级的虚拟设备
然后这样的话我们也可以接受
针对于SMD持年级的各种
提及各方面的优化
包括持年变形、数据变形等等
在右边的图中
我们是这样想展示的
是一个基于谈令的流水先兵优化
它的原理大概是这样
NPC的运算可以被当成是交替出现的本地计算和网络通信
当本地计算发生的时候
网络通信一般是盲等的
而当网络交互的时候CPU是空闲的
这样相当于计算和贷款资源
没有充分的得到利用
在这个优化中我们通过将矩针拆快
并且通过多项乘每个线程计算器中的一部分
这样可以让CPU和网络通信交迟在一起
让计算的同时也有另外一些线程在通信
从而整体的计算提高计算的吞吐量
同时SPU也支持安全协议的扩展
我们内置的支持了CME 2K,ABS3和其他三个协议
他们是实际上是几个典型的,比较性能比较好的2PC,3PC协议
同时我们开放了协议扩展接口
通过这样的方式我们可以支持两方、三方、多方
半征时、恶意等各种安全的模型
从而在安全性跟性能之间做一些折衷和妥协
还有一个重要的特点是SPU支持多种的部属模式
并且物理部属模式对上层逻辑是完全透明的
这样我们就可以面向SPU的虚拟机进行编程
并且得到一次书写到处执行的效果
这个怎么理解呢?我们举一个例子
右边相分为左右两部分
左边展示的是物理的layout
右边展示的是虚拟layout
然后集中原型的节点代表数据提供方
方形的节点代表计算方
然后右上图实际上是三个数据节点
将数据完全的拖拐到三个计算节点上
然后计算节点和数据节点是完全分离的
也就是我们通常所说的out sourcing模式
左下方数据提供方就数据节点
同时也参与了计算
就说他们所是clockade在一起的
就是所谓的clockade模式
这两种不同的物理部属
其中上面有6个节点
相关就是3个真正的物理节点
然后同时对应了右边的这个虚拟抽象
接着虚拟抽象中
我们有3个数据提供节点和1个虚拟的SPU
这样我们可以针对这个虚拟的抽象来携带码
然后这个分代码可以在所有的物理列表上进行执行
最后我们总结一下
SPU它的全称实际上是secure processing unit
从它的命名来看
就是想成为一个类似于CPU或者GPU的设备
从而支持上层的各种应用
类比来看
如果说CPU是一个物理的
同用的
还比较快的设备的话
那么GPU就是一个物理的
并且对并行计算友好的高性能的设备
那么SPU实际上是一个虚拟的
支持多方的带安全于的
相对较慢的一个设备
接下来我们来快速看一下SPU的编程界面
由于时间关系
我们会忽略一些细节
尽量给大家一个直观上的感受
右边实际上是一个百万富翁的程序
Alice和Bob各自随机一个数字
然后比较大小
当然在比较的过程中
除了比较结果
什么都不会知道对方具体的数字
可以看到我们所有的真正的逻辑
都是Python Jax NumPy直接书写的
比如说Random和Compile这两个函数
第二个用的都是NumberPy
或者是GNP NumPy的原生算字
所以它是一个AI的原生应用
接着我们通过SPU的JaxingTime
编译将Compile这个函数
编译成SPU的字节码
然后交给SPU的虚拟机进行执行
整个过程中用户实际上只用做三个事情
第一使用AI的框架
写好代码逻辑
比如说Random和Compile这两个函数
接着标注数据是来自哪一方
比如说第一个Random来自Alice
接下来个Random来自Bob
接着标注需要保护的函数
让它在SPU上执行
比如说Compile这个函数
让它被SPU保护的执行
用户实际上不需要
和外道隐私计算的领域知识
再举个例子
在右边这个代码里面
我们从Hug-in Face上
下载了一个GPTR的模型
然后放
然后将模型放置在Alice的设备上
将Propt放置在Bob的设备上
对应的就是Inputs ID
是将被放到了Alice
就是P1这个设备
然后Pretrained Model Parameters
是将被放到了P2这个设备
最后我们将推理
就是Text Generation这个函数
标注到SPU的设备上
执行这样我们就完成了
一个隐私保护的大模型的推理
可以看到通过这种模式
我们可以很容易的
迁移AI世界的代码
到隐私保护的世界
如果我们想要更改安全设定
只需要修改配置文件
然后无需要修改任何代码逻辑
右图展示了两种不同的安全配置
上方是由三个节点
Node0,Node1,Node2
然后运行API3协议
组成了一个SPU的虚拟设备
下方是由两个节点
Node0,Node1
运行其他组成的一个虚拟设备
对于算法的实践者
这些配置是无感的
它写的任何一个算法
都可以在两种不同的设备
不能协议上进行执行
最后SPU作为一个虚拟设备
也提供了配套的工具链的支持
比如说profiling, tracing和debugging工具
右图展示的实际上是
SPU Profiling 2的输出
可以看到这个profiler输出了
各层次的算子的一个执行次数
系它们消耗的时间
通过这些数据
我们就可以对上层的应用和
下层的协议进行一些针对性的优化
最后我们介绍现状和展望
首先SPU已经在银与生态中开源
是银与生态的重要组成部分
而且SPU结合银与生态的其他的组件
可以做很多有趣的事情
第一就是我们刚才所说
SPU可以很方便的支持隐私保护机器学习
同时SPU可以用来支持年帽学习
然后使用把SPU当成一个设备
来保护secure aggregation的过程
并且SPU作为一个计算设备
被集成在银与secure数据固中
用来进行安全的数据分析
同时因为隐私计算本身是一门高速发展的学科
所以SPU也可以被用来进行前约的学术研究
首先SPU自身中了系统类的会议
Euthanix AT323
然后它包含了SPU在系统方面做的一些工作
大家有兴趣的话可以读一下我们的论文
然后由SPU调节了原生AI和加密协议
所以SPU可以被方便的用来做隐私计算的各种研究
比如北大师生
基于SPU实现了针对MPC的Vision Transformer的算法和优化
然后结果被SACV23不用
然后还有个例子就是马云救援也据SPU
完成了一些首个Nama-CB大模型的隐私推理工作
Trimpaper也是被Hug-in-face Daily Papers推荐了
最后SPU作为AI和密码学之间的强调
我们也希望可以进一步加速构建隐私计算的生态
比如通过SPU提供的原生的NAMPA API
我们可以构建一个SQNLumLac的一个机器学习库
让仅仅的机器学习算法更容易的前移到隐私保护的世界里
我们也可以通过构造PandasLac的数据分析库
让人用户更方便
无感地做安全的数据分析
同时SPU自身也会支持更多的密码学后端
让隐私计算的性能更好使用场景更多
这就是今天的全部内容
谢谢大家收看